Planes, trains
and automobiles.
Sure, these marvels of modern technology
can get you somewhere fast.
But are they worth
all the hassle and risk?
No. You deserve better.
You deserve an airship.
And not just any airship.
I'm offering you a ride
in Google co-founder
Sergey Brin’s airship
made by the good people
at Lighter Than Air.
That's right, friends.
Airships are back again
and they're better than ever.
They're less slow.
They're less noisy.
They have windows that open.
That's crazy.
And now they're less
flammable, too.
So come on down to my hometown
of Mountain View, California
and hitch your ride
on the Pathfinder One.
About five years ago,
I got wind
that Sergey Brin
was funding the construction
of a secret airship right here
at NASA Ames in Mountain View.
I saw some
pictures of this early
airship.
Got kind of obsessed with it.
Sergey didn't want to talk
about his airship.
But over the last couple of years,
I managed to ingratiate myself
with the guy who's bringing
Sergey Brin’s airship to life.
And today
I'm going to take you guys in
to see this thing
being made.
I'm Alan Weston,
and I'm the CEO of LTA,
and I'm the first person
to work on this project.
We've got this beauty
behind us.
Give us, give us the basics.
This is Pathfinder one.
This is 122 meters long,
has about 28
tons of total lift.
It's designed to cruise
at maximum speed of 60 knots.
It could probably go over 2,000
nautical miles in one leg.
Our mission is to expand
and complement
existing humanitarian relief
using lighter
than air technology
and at the same time
reduce the carbon footprint
of aviation.
Al here might look like
your average aviation nerd,
but I assure you he's not.
Among other claims to fame,
he was a member
of the Dangerous Sports Club,
where he would do stuff
like this
and this.
He even performed
one of the first modern bungee
jumps.
People had sort of used vines
and things like that before,
but you guys were
the first ones
to get just a cord
and jump off a bridge, right?
Right.
It was an April Fools’ joke.
And so, yes.
And they let somebody like
you go work
for the Air Force after that.
Oh, actually, the Air Force
thought it was pretty funny.
Much like Al, airships
have a fascinating backstory.
Some of the first ones
the US ever made
lived right here in this hangar.
Almost 100 years ago,
the Navy began
building airships in Ohio
so they could be flown
to California.
The Navy saw these craft as key
to gathering intelligence
and performing reconnaissance.
It was the glory days
of airships.
You’ve shown me
some of these slides
just here in Silicon Valley.
There were times
when the sky was,
like, filled with airships
and they were doing
amazing things.
I mean, there’s one that was
almost like an aircraft carrier.
This was actually in 1932
and ‘33.
There was a hook on
the airship
and biplanes were carried
inside the airship.
And they were refueled.
Then of course, airships
had some very bad PR.
And planes came along,
and people lost interest
in these majestic beasts.
Large airships
disappeared in 1939.
So like everything
people might think of,
those are all blimps.
And the difference being,
a blimp
just has no rigid structure.
Right.
This is a rigid airship
with a skeleton.
And so the skeleton defines
the shape.
And Al thinks he can bring
these sexy, hard-bodied
airships back,
this time filled with nice,
non-flammable helium.
So you've got this
wonderful history
and you're, like,
making it all happen again.
Right, right.
Back to the future. Yeah.
We’re restarting, we’re awakening
the sleeping giants
is what I like to say.
It’s one of my favorite phrases.
Can we do the horn?
Sure.
I don't think anyone I've ever
heard anyone use it before.
This is Carl Taussig.
He's a mechanical engineer
I've known for years
who really gets around
Silicon Valley.
I asked him to give me
the grand tour.
It's a lot of scaffolding.
Yeah, it's incredible.
At first glance,
it appears almost nothing has
changed in a hundred years.
But really, this thing
is a mix of the super old
and the super new.
So this is one of 12
of the electric motors
that propel the ship.
Okay.
And it's you can see it's
motors mounted on a pylon
which can rotate.
So think of this airship
as a giant quadcopter.
All these are thrust vectored.
They can be pointed
in order to lift the ship
straight up or move laterally.
And then here,
this outer material is,
it’s kind of leveraged
from racing sailboats.
This is how it's laced on,
and this is a kind of
an anachronism from
the way airships were built
100 years ago.
There's
40,000 of these lacing tabs.
Each one is laced by hand.
Jeez.
The Pathfinder One’s skeleton is
made of carbon fiber, making it
lighter and stronger than past
airships.
The ship will run on diesel
to start,
but LTA hopes to switch
to either solar
or some form of hydrogen power
in the future.
Overall, the airship will be
much slower than a plane,
but at least the passengers
will feel virtuous
about their carbon footprint.
I've never been in a gondola.
Designed to seat about ten people.
It's used commercially
for sightseeing
by the Zeppelin company
on their NT airships.
And so if you're doing like a
two or three day
journey from London
to New York, you're just
you're hanging out in here
in this space.
Admittedly,
for a futuristic airship,
this is an underwhelming
interior.
But this ship is
just an experimental vehicle,
the first of its kind,
and not for the public.
And the company
has bigger things in mind
than just
leisurely sky cruises.
I think you guys are most
interested
in kind of disaster scenarios.
I mean, that's the heart of
why you're making this thing.
Right.
When you arrive at a disaster
site,
you often show up
and the place is wrecked.
And so
the port may not be working.
You then have to get your supplies
to where the disaster is.
And typically, you know,
the roads are gone.
Helicopters are really
expensive to operate.
They have limited range
and limited capacity
to lift things.
So that's where an airship can
also help.
And it's the cargo, right?
I mean, they can carry
a significant amount of stuff.
Right.
We've studied airships
that could carry up
to 200 tons of cargo.
Our approach is scalable
to build larger airships
that can carry even more.
All right, we've gone
tail to snout.
So this giant thing
is like a custom
made anchor, kind of.
Exactly.
This is what we call our
our mast trailer.
Okay.
It’s one of the major advantages
of an airship.
All you need to land is
one of these portable masts.
You know, we really
we hope to be flying
by the end of the year.
Yeah.
There's a lot to do, still.
Al promised my two kids
one of the first, first rides.
It'll be a great ride.
Your kids, the
flight test engineers.
Just keep them safe.
And as much as I want my kids
waving to me from the gondola
on that
very first flight...
I can't help
but imagine things going
horribly,
disastrously wrong.
It is unfortunate
that airships are synonymous
with fiery death.
But ever since that
fateful day in 1937,
one small town in Germany,
the home of the Hindenburg,
has led a PR campaign
to resuscitate
the airship’s image.
The dream of the zeppelin
is alive in Friedrichshafen.
The town is embedded
with airship propaganda.
And they start ‘em young.
This is your gaseous god.
There’s a parallel world
where this is the norm.
And I'll admit I'm jealous.
As far as weird stories go,
this one is wonderfully weird.
Count Ferdinand von Zeppelin
was a great airship pioneer
in the late
1800s and early 1900s,
and the man
could not be stopped.
He convinced all of Germany
to fund his work
in an early version
of a Kickstarter campaign,
and his company even managed
to convince the Allies into
letting Germany
keep making airships
after World War One.
The count died in 1917.
Shame.
But he donated
all his zeppelin
intellectual property
to the city
of Friedrichshafen.
Wunderbar!
And bizarrely,
his inventions were picked up
by the aerospace
and automotive industries
and turned into the basis
of a multi-billion-dollar
empire.
Friedrichshafen
gets a big chunk of this money
today, and its residents
get free vacations and free
education as a result.
Well done, count.
This museum is partly financed by the Zeppelin Foundation,
but so is the university, for example.
We also have kindergartens, swimming pools, etc.
So there is quite a bit of prosperity here that can be
traced back quite clearly
to Graf Zeppelin and his entrepreneurial spirit.
So he was really an innovative spirit,
and he actually founded the first Silicon Valley in Friedrichshafen.
Where does people's
fascination
with zeppelins come from?
You know, what, like,
why are these things
so interesting?
I think that has a lot to do with the Hindenburg, of course,
and with the accident of the Hindenburg.
Tragedy strikes. A terrific
explosion in the tail
fin of the dirigible
and passengers and crew
hurl themselves out of
the ship and to the ground.
Maybe if there wasn't video
and all this
reporting about this event,
maybe airships wouldn't
have fallen out of favor
as much as they did
for a period.
Right, exactly.
And it was also, of course, during the time of National Socialism.
And if you look at feature films today, for example,
or look at video games where the Zeppelin also appears
as an instrument of war or as a substitute for an airplane,
it’s often Nazis who are in these airships.
Despite their
reputation as both fiery
death traps
and Nazi tools of war...
I still want to ride one.
Thar she blows.
My airship awaits.
Everyone tells you how awesome
the experience is going to be.
Now they've talked me into it.
This is crazy.
You can like,
you feel this incline,
but so gently.
Holy **** man, this is crazy.
I genuinely feel like a wizard.
It’s like...
It's so hard to explain.
Like surfing in the sky.
Of course, the real wizards
sit up front.
Meet Katharine Board,
one of the zeppelin flying elite.
It's got to be a relatively
small club
out of all the pilot clubs.
Maybe this is the smallest? Or...
No- notice,
whenever you mention a pilot's
name, we tend to know them.
It's a very small club.
There are more astronauts
than airship pilots.
Okay. All right.
And so that means what,
we're talking about, like...
Uh, maybe
15 zeppelin pilots.
Okay.
The great
thing about flying an airship
is it’s fly by feel,
not by numbers.
The big airplanes, it’s
very much fly by numbers.
Yeah.
Okay yeah, there is a little bit
of feel and skill
when they finally actually do
touch the controls,
which is almost never.
But it's different every day.
And we go on the road
and we fly out of fields.
We fly out of big airports,
small airports.
There's something like,
I don't know
if magical is the right word.
It’s almost like an
illusion in your head, though,
to see this big thing
that kind of moves
gracefully,
but slowly and it's just so
unlike any other aircraft
you're used to.
It is a ship.
Just looking at
how the ship loading
and the center of buoyancy,
center of gravity,
center of lift, all these things
are exactly the same
because we do float.
We float in the air
just like a boat on the water.
Only difference is
you can't see the waves.
I got to poke my head
out the window.
Yeah do that, yeah.
That's crazy.
I feel like a dog.
Full happiness, everything.
You know, I don't love heights,
but when I stick my head out
the window, it's
not scary or anything
at all.
So cool.
Now there are these startups
trying to build new airships.
Is this like an exciting
time for you,
The idea that that maybe
we have new airships and
and this technology
is coming back again?
It’s a great idea and of course it would be great
if that would work out, the American project.
I’m curious to see if that can be achieved.
To find out if
the airship has a future,
I headed back to America.
Did I take a zeppelin?
Only in my dreams.
If Lighter Than Air
is successful,
then the future of the airship
will take place
not in Germany or Silicon
Valley...
But here, in Akron,
Ohio, where it all began
in the first place.
The Navy airships USS Akron
and USS Macon were built
here in the 1930s.
Goodyear kept going with this work
and created
its blimping empire.
Now Lighter Than Air
has taken over this facility
known as the airdock. It's
where Sergei's even bigger
airships will come to life.
Thank you for joining us
here in the Akron Airdock.
Behind me,
you can see the beginning
of our next airship
that we're building
right here in Akron.
It will be the largest airship
built in the United States
since the Macon
was built in 1932.
This is our very first test
section, and this is where
we're going to build
Pathfinder 3,
which will be 600 feet long
and a hundred feet in diameter
with a total lift of nearly
100 tons.
Why did you come
to this facility?
Just for the history
and the people, but I guess
just, and its size offers
you something else as well.
Yes. Here we are building
the airship factory
of the future.
We can build
larger airships here
year round, than you can build
anywhere else in the world.
So that's why we're here.
If you want to,
we can probably organize
someone to take you
to the top of the airdock.
What is it? An elevator?
Or do I have to climb?
No no, there’s a funicular
that takes you to the top.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go and organize that.
To take us up the funicular,
we grabbed Harry,
Pathfinder 3 program manager
and Ohio local.
This is the part
where I'm supposed to tell you
that it hasn't been certified
in 30 years.
Hundred year old equipment... no.
Okay, so everybody good?
Braced, ready?
I’m braced.
Up goes the 90-year-old
elevator.
Have I mentioned I’m
not a big fan of heights?
And one more.
Okay!
Okay.
You know, when you look up,
it looks kind of big, right?
But then whenever
you get here, you look down
and you see, like, trucks
and those gigantic-
Holy crap.
It looks like ants.
The truck looks like nothing.
Yeah, like a toy.
Wow, that is crazy.
This is making me feel
a little queasy.
When you work with people here
or you grow up around here,
everybody's got a story
about the airdock,
whether you had
great grandparents
or somebody
had worked here in the past,
or you have a lot of family
that worked for Goodyear.
Like I had grandparents
that worked at Goodyear.
But seeing the blimp overhead,
it didn't really mean
much as a kid.
It was a beautiful thing
and it's
such a cool thing to see it.
But then you realize, well,
this is really special
for, for us, right?
Because, you know,
you go a lot of places,
you don't really see this.
And so you just have this kind
of emotional attachment to it
every time you see it.
It almost feels like
this place has been waiting
patiently for decades
for airship building
to start up again.
And that's a lovely notion.
But there's every reason
to think
all of this might fail.
Sergey, in fact, has invested
in airships before.
He backed a company called
Airship Ventures
that flew people on joy rides
around the Bay Area.
But it folded
after a couple of years.
Long range trips? Hauling
hundreds of tons of cargo?
Even dicier.
So what do you make of
LTA and Sergey?
You've got this guy
who's got enough money
to do whatever he wants
and he's not even immediately
going after tourism,
is going more after,
he says, disaster
relief and cargo.
I mean, is it
exciting to see somebody
trying to build
an new large ship?
It must be for you
to have somebody
putting money into this.
How honest do you
want me to be?
Very honest.
Okay.
I don't want to piss off
any of these companies
and kudos to them for
giving it a go.
But to this day,
I find it difficult
to imagine the cargo.
Yeah.
Disaster relief.
I find that difficult.
I think that's going to take
a very long time.
I'm not saying
it's impossible,
but it's going to take
a very long time to iron
out the issues
with something that big.
Al Weston, though,
remains a true believer.
I'm curious
where you see all this going.
I know when you give your
history of airships,
you start by saying, I'm
Al Weston, I’m here
to darken the skies,
which would imply
that you want to make
a lot of airships, you know?
Is that the plan
or is this, is this, you know,
a limited number of vehicles
for the disaster relief
type efforts?
What are you picturing?
From the beginning of this
I've been really intrigued
about the question,
can these airships be made quickly
and affordably enough to be
mass produced?
Is, does it make sense to make
100 or a thousand?
Studies have suggested that
there is a market,
but can we actually do it?
I think that we’re standing
on the shoulders of giants,
but at the same time,
we're leveraging
new technologies,
new software, new materials
that the people in the past
could only have dreamt of.
I believe that
we can make a lot of airships,
but we have to complete
the first one.
Right.
There are plenty of reasons
why airships aren't practical.
They're slow,
they're complicated,
they're expensive.
They can only fly in specific
weather conditions.
The list goes on.
But there's a feeling
that you get when you see
these massive sky whales
drifting through the clouds.
It's a feeling of wonder
and of whimsy.
And I think it's that feeling
that keeps the dreams
of airships aloft.